Salut les mentalos !
Je vous fait une dernière vidéo de mémoire, pour vous faciliter la vie.
Cette semaine, je vous ai reparlé de la table de rappel en vous renvoyant vers un ancien Master Class que j'avais fait en début d'année sur la table de rappel.
Et entre les messages privés sur Facebook, sur Twitter, vous m'avez envoyé des Snaps, sur Instagram, j'ai eu des mails de ça, des commentaires dans la vidéo...
Me disant que soit vous avez du mal à construire votre propre table de rappel, parce que vous n'aviez pas d'idée,
soit vous aviez du mal à l'apprendre.
J'ai arrêté de compter au bout de 500 messages.
Pour plutôt faire cette vidéo, plutôt que de répondre à tout le monde individuellement.
Donc voici L'ULTIME méthode !
On va utiliser le principe du "système major" ou du "grand système", ça a pleins pleins de noms. Ca a été un très vieux système mnémotechnique.
Le principe de base est très simple, vous allez coder les chiffres par des consonnes.
On remplace le 0 par un S ou un Z, [ce] ou [ze].
On remplace le 1 par un T ou un D.
On remplace le 2 par un N, parce que sur le N il y a deux pieds quand on fait un n.
Le 3 du coup, par un M.
Le 4 par un R, le 5 par un L,
le 6, alors par tous les sons comme [je], comme une geôle, et par CH pour tous les mots en [cheu].
Le 7, on le remplace par un K comme kiwi, par QU comme quincailler, ou par, par... [réfléchi]
Je n'ai pas d'idée...
Oui si ! J'ai une idée !
Par les "gueu" comme gare, ou comme gorille, ou comme guillemets.
Le 8, par les sons et consonnes F ou V, comme Fabien ou Vous mentalise.
Et enfin 9 par B ou P. B comme Benoit ou P comme Patrick.
Et pour construire vos images de table de rappel, il suffit d'utiliser ces consonnes en rajoutant des voyelles pour former un mot.
Exemple concret sur la date d'aujourd'hui:
Nous sommes le 10 septembre, donc le 10/09.
Donc "10" c'est 1-0.
Et 1, on sait que c'est T ou D.
0 c'est le son S ou [ze]
Donc [ss] ou [ze].
Donc l'image ça pourrait être un dessin, ça pourrait être un tesson de bouteille, ça pourrait être une toison, ça pourrait être un tison.
Et puis pour septembre c'est 09. Donc c'est 0 et 9.
0 c'est [ce] ou [ze], 9 c'est B ou P.
Donc on pourrait faire un sablier, ou un sapin, ou un zombie, un zébu...
Dernier exemple: 64 ça pourrait faire une écharpe.
Parce que [cheu] et [peu]
Allez on ce le tente à l'envers.
Je vous laisse le code là sur le coté, je vous donne une image, et vous essayez à l'inverse quel chiffre c'est.
Va pour une bougie.
Bougie.
Bougie. [lentement]
Bougie. Le [beu] de 9, le G de 6, donc c'est 96.
Deuxième coup encore plus simple, une momie.
Une momie, une momie.
Ah ! Une momie. [imite]
Dans "momie", il y a juste deux M, deux fois le son M.
Deux fois la consonne M.
Donc c'est 33.
Cette méthode, c'est surement la plus ancienne pour construire une table de rappel,
et c'est surement également, la plus efficace.
Elle est efficace pour vous aider à trouver de images jusqu'à 100, et même plus, même au-delà.
Et elle est très efficace également, pour l'inverse, pour s'en rappeler, pour travailler sa table de rappel puisqu'il y a un codage spécifique.
N'hésitez pas à regarder la vidéo consacrée à l'utilisation de la table ensuite.
J'espère que cette méthode vous aidera à compléter toute la playlist sur la mémoire.
Dites moi dans les commentaires si il y a d'autres applications de la mémoire que vous aimeriez que j'aborde,
ou sur des points très spécifiques, des domaines très spécifiques.
J'aime bien vous donner des méthodes sur un sujet en particulier plutôt qu'un généraliste.
N'oubliez pas de mettre un pouce en l'air et de vous abonner à la chaine.
Et rendez-vous demain à 11H, oui parce que hier j'ai dit 17H mais c'est 11H que je voulais dire.
Et bien à demain !
Ciao !
Je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23 septembre à la Garenne-Colombes, c'est la date la plus proche de Paris, si jamais vous voulez venir sinon, il y a toutes les dates de tournée sur mon site !